Grant doesn't have time to work with us anymore, because he's so busy selling
tons of glasses wipers and nozzles. And plus, he already learned a ton from us
about algebra. So, he's referred me to someone else who he thinks is going to
help put a new spin on ways that algebra shows up in the real world. Our new
friend is his cousin, Athena. She says hello, and she is super excited to start
working with us. Now, just to give you some basic info about Athena. She is a
college student living in UdaCity. In school, she is majoring in architecture,
but she's still taking classes in some other subjects, including college
algebra. Athena loves hanging out with her friends and her family and she has a
really cute dog and a really cute cat. So, all in all, Athena leads a pretty
happy life.